quand j'étais gamin
ma grand mère et mes parents m'ont
acheté des livres d'histoire car
j'aimais beaucoup ça et en lisant ces
livres d'histoire il y avait quelque
chose de marquant pour moi je voyais
quand 200 300 ans des progrès
considérables avaient été faits que
grâce à ces progrès je vivais dans un
monde extraordinaire et en même temps il
y avait beaucoup de gens qui n'en
bénéficient pas y compris dans mon
propre pays et de cette émotion de cette
indignation d'enfants est sorti une
question comment construire une société
plus harmonieuse
alors j'ai essayé de penser différemment
j'ai fait des études d'histoire bien sûr
mais aussi de psycho déco de finances et
j'ai découvert une un domaine
scientifique très peu connue qui donnait
des réponse à ma question et en tant que
chercheur je suis devenu spécialiste
notamment dans ce domaine et ce domaine
ce sont les politiques du bonheur les
politiques du bonheur alors avant de
parler de politique du bonheur je vais
vous parler de bonheur c'est quoi le
bonheur
pourquoi le bonheur serait un facteur
d'harmonie sociale
je rencontre des des personnes qui me
disent mais définir le bonheur c'est
impossible
je ne pense pas je connais beaucoup de
définition scientifique et parmi ces
définitions
il y en a une qui me semble plus
pertinente et c'est la suivante nous
vivons un flux quasi-continue d'émotions
positives et négatives et être heureux
c'est vivre beaucoup plus d'émotions
positives
que d'émotions négatives avec une nuance
les émotions positives peuvent avoir des
conséquences négatives et les émotions
négatives
peuvent avoir des conséquences positives
alors pourquoi le bonheur serait un
facteur d'harmonie sociale
pourquoi le bonheur serait
vraisemblablement l'outil le plus
puissant d'harmonie sociale que nous
ayons à notre disposition
et bien parce que le bonheur et
humanisant le bonheur permet la
rencontre en grande partie entre nos
besoins personnels et l'harmonie sociale
au niveau de nos besoins personnels en
général on préfère être heureux que
malheureux et puis lorsqu'on est heureux
de manière durable
eh bien on bénéficie des conséquences
positives du bonheur par exemple sur
l'espérance de vie
les chercheurs qui ont comparé les des
lettres d'aspirants tu nommes des années
1920 1930 et ils ont vu que c'est
aspirante nonne par des aspirantes au
nom de celle qui avait écrit bhl plus
d'émotions positives avaient eu une
durée de vie supérieure de quasiment 11
ans assène qui avait écrit le moins
d'émotions positives
et puis le bonheur c'est bon pour
l'harmonie sociale
quand on est heureux de manière quasi
automatique on développe des
comportements pro sociaux par exemple la
gentillesse la gratitude et puis on
s'est aperçu que lorsqu'on cherche à
accroître ses comportements pro sociaux
de manière naturelle
on devient plus heureux et c'est pour ça
que le bonheur est un outil aussi
puissant d'harmonie sociale parce qu'il
fait le lien entre l'harmonie sociale et
nos besoins personnels il y à un autre
poids aussi qui est important
essentiel même s'il peut paraître simple
le bonheur et augmente table améliorable
si ça n'était pas le cas et bien le
bonheur ne pourrait pas être un outil
d'amélioration
et lorsqu'on pense amélioration du
bonheur on le pense généralement au
niveau individuel mais comme nous allons
le voir il y a beaucoup de choses qui se
joue au niveau collectif et c'est pour
ça que les politiques du bonheur sont
essentielles politique du bonheur c'est
considérer que le bonheur est un repère
voir un but des politiques publiques
politiques du bonheur ses pensées les
politiques publiques en fonction des
émotions positives et négatives qu'elles
génèrent mais il faut faire attention
lorsqu'on parle de bonheur il faut pas
qu'il y ait d'injonction au bonheur il
faut pas que le bonheur de vienne
tyrannie et pour éviter ça il ya un
cadre à respecter et ce cadre peut être
le suivant le bonheur c'est quelque
chose de privé d'un team nous avons
chacun le droit d'être malheureux et que
ce malheur soit respectée et les
politiques du bonheur sont uniquement là
pour donner un cadre favorable
pas plus alors j'ai été très théorique
et maintenant je vais vous proposer deux
voire trois exemples le premier exemple
c'est la justice réparatrice la justice
réparatrice est une forme de justice qui
met au centre du processus judiciaire la
réparation émotionnelle de la victime
alors de manière pratique ça peut aller
jusqu'à ce qu'au fait que la victime et
le coupable se rencontrent le coupable
dans une dynamique d'empathie vis-à-vis
de la souffrance qu'il a infligées à la
victime et la victime dans une dynamique
de pardon
et lorsqu'on regarde les résultats de ce
type de justice on s'aperçoit que les
victimes
on sent beaucoup plus satisfaite de ce
processus judiciaires qu'elles vont
beaucoup moins chez le médecin pour des
problèmes psychiques mais aussi pour des
problèmes physiques
et puis du côté des coupables on
s'aperçoit qu'ils sont eux aussi
beaucoup plus satisfait du processus
judiciaire qui a beaucoup moins de
récidive
et lorsqu'il ya récidive elle est de
moindre ampleur autre exemple les
politiques d'abondance en temps les
politiques d'abondance entend plutôt que
les politiques traditionnels d'abondance
en richesse la recherche nous montre que
au delà d'un certain niveau de richesse
qui peut varier selon les personnes
pour être plus heureux il faut pas plus
d'argent il faut plus de temps libre
la recherche montre aussi que nous avons
tendance à mal évalué l'argent qui est
nécessaire pour être heureux
nous avons tendance en fait à le
surévalué et aujourd'hui on peut se dire
que dans les pays riches
le niveau de production est suffisant
pour passer à des politiques d'abondance
en temps et en fait le problème ce n'est
pas un manque de richesse ce sont les
inégalités financières
et lorsqu'on regarde un peu le futur on
voit qu'il ya des technologies qui
arrive qui vont permettre d'augmenter la
productivité par exemple la robotique ou
l'impression 3d
peut-être vous savez que aujourd'hui
avec une imprimante 3d il est possible
de construire en une journée
l'essentiel d'une maison ces
technologies peuvent être le futur des
politiques du bonheur peuvent le
permettre mais il ya un souci
les personnes qui investissent
aujourd'hui dans ces technologies sont
celles qui ont l'argent et les personnes
qui vont perdre leur emploi sont celles
qui n'ont pas l'argent est là les
politiques du bonheur disent quelque
chose de tout à fait simple donne une
indication tout à fait simple
moins d'inégalités et une meilleure
répartition de la charge de travail
dernier exemple quelque chose que vous
avez tous connus et moi aussi
l'école aujourd'hui le le but de l'école
c'est fabriquer le futur travailleur le
futur citoyen dans une approche par par
le bonheur le but de l'école c'est le
bonheur ici maintenant des élèves des
enfants et c'est important parce que si
on se préoccupe du bonheur des parents
et des adultes
et bien c'est normal de s'occuper du
bonheur des enfants et puis on sait
aussi que le bonheur présent ça vaut
pour les enfants mais ça vaut aussi pour
vous le bonheur présent favorise le
bonheur futur
et si on investit aujourd'hui sur
l'honneur des enfants
eh bien ce sera un investissement qui ne
sera pas faire plus tard et puis le
bonheur à l'école ça favorise la
performance les enfants préfèrent
apprendre par le jeu est sans doute que
vous aussi
enfin les tous les enfants ne deviennent
pas des adultes
il y a des enfants qui meurent avant de
devenir adulte est la question que nous
pouvons nous poser c'est quel projet
pour eux est ce que le projet c'est de
les former à être de futurs travailleurs
qui ne seront pas ou est ce que le
projet c'est leur bonheur ici et
maintenant
au final les politiques du bonheur ne
résoudrons pas tous les problèmes qui
existent c'est pas une nouvelle main
invisible d'adam smith mais elles
permettront de résoudre un certain
nombre de problèmes et de construire une
société plus heureuse et donc plus
harmonieuse et la question que je
souhaite vous posez c'est est vous prêt
à prendre le risque d' expérimenter des
politiques du bonheur pour construire
une société à la fois plus heureuse
et plus harmonieuse quant à moi j'espère
que dans quarante cinquante ans il y
aura des petits enfants comme celui que
j'ai été qui pourront ouvrir des livres
d'histoire et lire que nous avons eu
l'intelligence émotionnelle de mettre en
place des politiques du bonheur je vous
remercie